[Musique]
et si c'était quelqu'un qui l'avait tuée
genre qui chie pas d'être un tueur au
vortex serial killer mais ça serait trop
strauss télé on vraiment j'adore ils
savent à quelle heure mais moi aussi
j'aime beaucoup ça du coup ceux qui
tomberaient fois j'avoue j'ai là mais ça
c'est des gens qui tuent d'autres
personnes enfin je sais pas un peu
d'humanité quoi puis penser à valentine
non mais j'avoue moi aussi me facile je
passe d'être un peu bizarre on arrive
nous fascine tous valentine de celles
accueillant ne veux pas que tu aies il
fait vendre
quoi qu en dise ted bundy est kemper et
consorts ont malheureusement été élevé
au rang d'icône de 1,71 ont fortement
influencé la culture populaire
américaine
on peut trouver aux états unis du
merchandising à leur effigie et des
objets leur ayant appartenu se vend
parfois à prix d'or et je ne parle pas
des centaines de lettres que les tueurs
en série reçoivent en prison de la part
de leurs fans quand il ne se marie pas
tout simplement avec elle sans eux il
est très probable que tout un pan de
l'imaginaire de fiction n'existerait pas
qu'il s'agisse du silence des agneaux
seven ou encore american psycho les
films et séries qui ont été inspirés par
les tueurs en série se comptent par
milliers selon imdb ait une bonne partie
d'entre eux sont devenus cultes c'est
assez cocasse quand on sait que
l'inventeur de l'expression si un humain
canin l'agent spécial robert hensler du
fbi qui inspire ebeam edge la série
manhunters aurait trouvé ce terme en
référence au sérieux les fameux
feuilleton qui était diffusée semaine
après semaine en première partie des
longs métrages dans les salles de cinéma
et qui avait beaucoup de succès à
l'époque mais comment expliquer ce star
system du mal et leur influence toujours
si fort dans la pop culture actuelle
alors que tout ça va totalement à
l'encontre de toutes les normes morales
sociales et légales que l'on accueille
depuis notre naissance et l'a peut-être
parce que bon nombre de ces tueurs
souhaitée au plus profond d'eux-mêmes
devenir ces icônes et qu'à cause une
forme de fascination bakar au plus
profond de nous mêmes nous les y avons
aidé pour la criminologue liger négrier
dormant le tueur en série est souvent un
psychopathe motivé par un désir et
narcissique d'exercer un pouvoir extrême
de vie et de mort
semblable au pouvoir des forces
supérieures telles dieu c'est là qu'en
tant que criminel en à un paradoxe
certains d'entre eux ont envie de
poursuivre leurs crimes sans se faire
prendre mais en même temps il ya une
grande frustration de ne pas être
reconnu pour ce qui est l'oeuvre de leur
vie et selon l'avis de schmidt un
chercheur américain spécialiste de la
question nous exerçons le souhait de
reconnaissance de cette tumeur en
faisant d'eux de véritables célébrités
par la fascination qu'ils existent
sur nous alors qu'on a tendance à croire
que la célébrité vont méritants et au
talentueux la vérité est tout autre
la célébrité est simplement synonyme de
présence sur la scène médiatique est
malheureusement plus un crime est
horrible plus les médias en parlent plus
l'auteur de ces crimes sera médiatisée
plus l'intérêt qui lui sera porté par un
public sera fort plus la demande en
temps de parler à nouveau sera grande
plus il marquera les esprits plus il
s'installera dans la culture populaire
plus l'influencera des oeuvres de
fiction plus ses oeuvres auront du
succès etc etc
il suffit donc de marquer les esprits
peu importe que ce soit en bien ou en
mal
c'est pour ça que charles manson a eu sa
place sur les couvertures de l'âge
magazine au même titre que marie monroe
auparavant assoiffé de célébrités et
n'arrivant pas à réaliser son rêve de
percer dans la musique qu'il usait de
son influence naturel pour devenir un
gourou et ensuite un tueur en série par
procuration vu qu'ils n'auraient
apparemment tué personne de cema et s'il
a tant marqué les esprits c'est parce
qu'il s'est approprié les codes de la
culture hippie pour y mettre
définitivement un terme et marquer la
fin de l'insouciance et du peace and
love des années 60 en devenant au début
des années 70 ce qu'on pourrait appeler
une contrée caunes les tueurs en série
sont donc par définition des personnages
publics et qui dit personnages publics
dits personal branding en gros le
personal branding ou marketing personnel
ou de soi-même consiste à considérer une
personne comme une marque et le market
et qu'on marque est un produit ou un
service
et si je vous dis ça c'est parce que
pour mieux comprendre notre fascination
pour les tueurs en série et leur
influence dans la culture populaire je
vous propose de les analyser sous un
angle marketing afin de vous montrer
pourquoi la série qui leur a tout d'une
marque à succès et pour ça on veut
utiliser ce qu'on appelle le prisme
d'identité de la marque le prisme
l'identité de la marque été développée
par jean noël kapferer en 1992 ce prisme
consiste à des pas l'identité d'une
marque dans ce cas ci le tueur et sa
projection vers le consommateur dans ce
cas ci nous afin d'analyser le rapport
qu'il est entre les deux ce prisme se
compose de six face d'un côté le
physique la personnalité et les valeurs
de la marque de l'autre côté la relation
qui lie entre elles et le consommateur
le ressenti interne de ce dernier et
l'image qu'il dégage via le rapport
qu'il entretient avec cette marque mais
avant de comprendre comment les serial
killers ont dû les influenceurs il faut
qu'on soit sûr de quoi on parle
précisément quand on dit serial killer
tu vois la criminologie s'est pas
vraiment du droit en fait c'est un truc
qui est pluridisciplinaire en fait on
voit pas que du droit du coup bah moi je
sais pas un truc que j'ai étudiée mais
c'est quand même super intéressant parce
que tu as en séries tu vois c'est pas
vraiment une définition juridique qui le
retrouve pas dans le code pénal par
exemple c'est vraiment des psychiatres
et psychanalystes ou je ne sais quoi qui
vont poser ce mot là nous en droit on va
pas parler de turin
mais du coup il n'y a aucun moyen de
joie de définir ce que savait le killer
précisément du coup bah si tu as quand
même des gens qui vont essayer de le
définir
notamment il faut avoir fait plusieurs
crimes dans un autre espace de temps
assez définis tu vois et je n'ai
vraiment le truc qu'on remarque c'est
que les tueurs en série ils connaissent
pas leurs victimes
mais tu as quand tu es une femme d'à
plus de chances d'être violentée
sexuellement ou tués par exemple tu
connais la lecture en séries je venais
souvent la victime qui connaissent pas
du tout c'est alors qu'ils en veulent
pas la personne particulièrement ceux
plus parce que là c'est une proie idéale
et du coup ce qui est très compliqué
c'est que comme il n'y a pas de lien
entre la victime et le tueur c'est
comment est-ce que tu remets la main sur
le tueur dans les agents du fbi qui ont
essayé de faire un portrait pour voir un
petit peu le profilage de la personne en
question de ça comme la soldate moment
c'est plutôt bien foutu dans cette série
et du coup pour essayer de voir un petit
peu parce qu'il a une signature est ce
que il a un mode opératoire très
particulier est ce que les victimes
toujours même profil et tout ça mais
c'est un exercice qui est très très
complexe
du coup t'as pas d'existence légale dans
le code pénal français du tueur en série
on ne va pas dire telle personne tu es
condamné à temps parce que tu es un
tueur en série
par contre on a 150 cas qu'il pourrait
rentrer dans cette définition qui
corresponde à la caractéristique de ne
pas connaître la personne c'est ça ouais
non après skins ou c'est qu'on les
qualifie toujours de monstres en fait
ces débours ouais non mais en fait tu es
déshumanise en faisant ce à quoi on
s'interroge jamais à bas comment
pourquoi est ce qu'ils ont fait ça en
fait c'est quoi leur profit qu'est ce
qu'ils ont écrit dans leur enfance
ça s'explique ramasse que dire c'est que
ça reste des monstres toi c'est aussi ça
qui le rend iconique qui les rend cool
qu'il est ce qu'on passe des stars de
rock non plus le premier point est
l'aspect physique ce qui est tangible ce
qu'on peut voir pour une marque il
s'agirait de son logo de son packaging
par exemple selon les statistiques des
auteurs français senninger eagle et
cannes
les femmes représentent seulement 5 à
10% des tueurs enserrée entre 73 84 % de
ces criminels sont de type caucasien et
60% d'entre eux avaient moins de 30 ans
lorsqu'ils ont commis leur premier crime
neutre archétype de tueur en série est
donc un mâle blanc de moins de 30 ans
elle ne se distingue pas au niveau
physique il peut donc mener une vie
normale
aller bruncher joue à la pétanque ou que
sais-je qu'un tueur sévi mais n'a pas
encore été attrappée les médias vont lui
attribue un surnom et ça ça lui donne
déjà un côté super villa qui le rend
déjà iconique aouam que l'on connaisse
sa réelle identité
l'ogre de santa cruz le dévie sur deux
têtes pour être kemper le lady killer
pour ted bundy ou tout simplement ce bon
vieux jack l'éventreur
ce surnom est souvent basée sur ce qu'on
appelle la signature du tueur parce que
pour atur la signature c'est ce qui fait
que le meurtre est différent d'un autre
ce qui le rend unique et qui reproduit à
chaque fois c'est un acte compulsif
ancré dans la nature profonde du tueur
quelque chose qui ne peut s'empêcher de
faire et qui est en partie à conscient
c'est d'ailleurs souvent ce qui trahit
un tueur car permet à la police de
connecter les crimes entre eux les
tueurs en série sont réputés pour être
très charismatique ce stéréotype
évidemment influencé la fiction que ce
soit anthony hopkins ou mat mikkelsen
dans hannibal kevin speccy dans seven ou
encore kristen bell dans american psycho
bien qu'il ne s'agisse pas d'une
généralité ça vient pas de nulle part le
procureur vincent bugliosi en charge du
dossier charles manson décrivez qu'il
avait une aura à définissable où qu'ils
aillent les gens graviter autour de lui
et c'est pour ça qu'on le considère
avant tout comme un gourou
et quand ils ne sont pas justes
charismatique ils sont carrément bg
comme ted bundy tellement beau parleur
élégant et charismatique qu'il faisait
rire l'auditoire pendant son procès et
n'hésitez pas à faire des clins d'oeil à
la caméra à l'époque de nombreuses
femmes refusé de le reconnaître coupable
à cause de son physique avantageux comme
l'expliqué et melliti bat autrice et est
spécialisée tueur en série
et pas la tête de l'emploi on se
figurent les tueurs comme méchant lait
est affreux et si l'un d'entre eux est
beau on va se dire qu'il ne veut pas
réellement commettre des actes
monstrueux cela est dû à un biais
cognitif qu'on appelle l'effet de halo
et qui fait qu'on perçoit manière
sélective des informations allant dans
le sens d'une première impression en
gros une caractéristique jugée positive
a reproduit une personne a tendance à
rendre plus positive les autres
caractéristiques
même si on ne les connaît pas c'est pour
cette raison que l'interprète de ted
bundy dans l'adaptation de netflix et
zac efron un choix controversé car
l'acteur jugé trop bg pour le rôle
aurait tendance à glorifier le
tristement célèbre tueur en série un
choix pourtant pertinent puisque bien
avant cela lors de la sortie d'un simple
documentaire montrant le vrai ted bundy
on avait pu lire des femmes sur twitter
dire ted bundy est vraiment mignon
netflix avait d'ailleurs publiquement
réagi sur twitter avec nous avons vu
passer beaucoup de discussions sur le
prétendu sex-appeal de ted bundy et nous
voudrions gentiment rappelé à tout le
monde qu'il y a littéralement des
milliers d'hommes sexy sur la plateforme
dont la plupart n'ont pas été reconnus
coupables de meurtres en série autres
car malgré la communication de la série
yu mettant en avant que personnage est
dangereux
beaucoup de jeunes femmes considérées la
série comme romantique l'acteur penn
bagdley a même réagi sur twitter en
rappelant bien qu'il interprète en
meurtrier je me demande si ça pourrait
être florence elle se sont pris la tête
quand charles est dû signer le bail vous
dire que charles avait pas été très
coopérative non mais c'est n'importe
quoi ce contrat il faut tout reprendre à
l'âme et les choses à modifier non mais
dans ce pays a quand même des lois sur
les respecte pas c'est la fin du monde
civilisé un nom mais signe pas n importe
quoi il faut tout modifier sacré charlet
ça va à florence en mettra c'est un
mobile en tout cas les femmes aiment
bien le poison je crois peut-être
qu'elle a fait son coup avant la soirée
[Musique]
cependant il est important de noter que
l'archétype du tueur en série hbo et
charmeur est largement exagérée et ne
représente bien entendu par la majorité
des cas du coup on va parler la
personnalité dans lequel une marque elle
détermine son tonneau voice ou
comportements son attitude c'est ce
qu'elle dit comment elle le dit et ce
qu'elle fait cela va essentiellement
déterminer la façon dont elle va
communiquer dans ses publicités
dans notre cas un tueur en série s ou un
psychopathe avec un manque d'empathie et
un certain sadisme mais ce qui le
caractérise c'est l'ambivalence
affective
le fait qu'il ait en moins social et
innocents qu'ils puissent cohabiter avec
l'envi meurtrière qu'il a au fond de lui
le tueur en série dissimule une envie
insatiable de crime qui mêlent souvent
sexe et mort et surtout à plaisir qu'il
tire de ses actes par un sentiment très
fort de supériorité
comme nous l'avons dit plus tôt il a
généralement une personnalité
narcissique de nice raiders se sont
nommés lui-même bt car en référence à
son mode opératoire et entretenait des
relations épistolaires avec la police et
la presse démontrant chez lui à profonde
narcissisme et un besoin manifeste de
célébrités c'est d'ailleurs ce jeu de
supériorité avec la police qui a causé
sa perte
nous pouvons également parlé du tueur du
zodiaque qu'il ne s'est jamais fait
attrapé alors qu'il gérait une véritable
stratégie de communication qui
consistait à envoyer des lettres à la
presse incluant quatre cryptogramme dont
trois n'ont à ce jour pas été élucidée
selon la pédopsychiatre catherine
jousselme c'est ce genre de choses qui
ont influencé la manière de présenter
les tueurs dans la fiction qui fait
passer ces psychopathes pour des gens
intelligents brillant et très fort il
semble supérieur d'une certaine façon au
commun des mortels
et même s'il faut noter que par exemple
ed kemper avaient un qi supérieur à
celui d'einstein dans la majorité des
cas la réalité est tout autre
l'archétype du tueur en série il très
intelligent n'est pas si courant on peut
justement voir de la série manhunter que
les agents du fbi sont presque déçu de
voir que le tueur williams pierce est en
réalité très peu intelligent en effet
dans certains cas plus rares le tueur
peut présenter un profil psychotique
plutôt que psychopathe une minorité
atteint de troubles mentaux tels que la
schizophrénie sont des psychotiques
compulsif qui tue de façon impulsive et
désorganisés mais sont quand même
considérer comme des tueurs en série le
psychotique désorganisé aurait
l'intelligence moyenne une instabilité
professionnels et mental sera
socialement immature improvisera son
crime et paniquera durant l'acte c'est
pourquoi la distinction la plus répandue
fait par l'unité des sciences du
comportement du fbi se situe entre
tueurs organisé et tueurs désorganisée
par exemple le joker de heath ledger
delattre
j de nolan s'apparente au tueur
psychopathe tandis que le joker de l'uac
in phoenix du film de todd phillips a
paru plutôt au tueur psychotique les
raisons de leur personnalité complexe
sont multifactorielles il n'existe pas
d'éléments qui expliquent
systématiquement qu'est ce qui les a
fait basculer dans la violence
même s'il a été constaté que 90 % des
tueurs en série ont subis dans l'enfance
des sévices sexuels ou des violences
physiques ou morales et là on arrive à
un élément important du marketing
le storytelling le storytelling est une
méthode de communication qui se base sur
une structure narrative qui empruntent
aux comptes et aux récits pour générer
de l'émotion mettre en avant un passé
tragique
une fêlure en lui qui raconte une
histoire dans laquelle tout le monde
peut se reconnaître
afin d'expliquer son comportement
déviant est un moyen utilisé dans la
fiction pour créer de l'empathie pour un
tueur le rendre presque attachant est
excusable
même dans le cas où une fiction est tiré
de la réalité elle est romancé pour
qu'un maximum de personnes puissent se
l'approprier et se mettre à la place du
tueur
ainsi la fiction ne fait qu'amplifier la
fascination qui ont tourné tueur en
série tout ça permet donc de créer un
personnage de fiction bien écrit mais
c'est également fréquemment utilisés par
les vrais tueurs en série qui se
présente très souvent comme des victimes
à leurs interlocuteurs
c'est une manière pour eux de se
déresponsabiliser leurs actes ou alors
sans et créatif le simple fait qu'ils
servent de la mort de ma cousine pour
faire son premier épisode de cette
saison c'est un ami et il s'entendait
mal avec charles esche croit façon je
connais on a cru soit 10 sur les sétois
qui veut des fichiers la sauvette aurait
pu passer la brosse un truc comme ça
afin merde et vous connaissez la
différence entre sur les arts à mort
c'est pas l'odeur en tout cas mais je
sais pas si ça colle avec qui il est au
fond toutes marques à des valeurs
piliers qui lui permettent de s'ancrer
dans le réel comme pour n'importe quel
être humain on a tous des choses
auxquelles on croit
c'est d'ailleurs l'élément qui va faire
qu'une marque est durable ou non ces
valeurs évoluent avec le temps pour être
en accord avec la société afin que le
consommateur s'y retrouve et ce qui est
si intriguant dans le cas des tueurs en
série c'est qu'il y en a pas y'a aucune
valeur auquel serial killer à 15
aujourd'hui le mal à l'état pur mais est
ce réellement une valeur en soi même si
c'était le cas elle est justement en
opposition avec la société et personne
n'est supposé s'est retrouvée le
problème c'est que le tueur en série no
plus généralement pas par idéologie par
fanatisme
pas non plus par appât du gain le seul
moteur du tueur en série est
généralement le sentiment de toute
puissance que lui procurent ces crimes
on peut voir que dans le cloud joker le
protagoniste dans ce malgré lui un
mouvement de foule emprunt de nombreuses
valeurs relatives à la lutte des classes
sauf que lui n'a pas choisi ses valeurs
c'est la foule qui lui est attribué lui
est davantage comblé par la
reconnaissance qu'on lui donne et le
pouvoir qu il en obtient et le pouvoir
peut être une motivation mais pas une
valeur en soi
en bref pour beaucoup de psychiatre
psychologue et criminologue les tueur en
série savent très bien ce qu'ils veulent
faire
mais ne savent pas vraiment plus que
nous pourquoi ils le font et c'est sans
doute cette envie de les comprendre
qu'ils créent ce rapport à la fois si
floue et si particulier que l'on peut
avoir avec eux monter je sais pas ma
cousine l'aimé bien peut-être un peu
trop ses mains est-ce que tu branle dans
mon lit il y à un mollet le j'ai c'est
que l'or se cache un coeur des pigeons
[ __ ] valentini encore ta cousine qu'a
pété une durite la satire est pas on lui
prend un biais pour chez pas valence et
nous parle du score qu'on n'en parle
plus près je sais pas si c'est un mobile
elle lui a pas fait le coup plus de
quatre ou cinq fois
[Musique]
il ya toujours une relation qui connecte
une marque et un consommateur il s'agit
du niveau d'affection de passion qu'il
est entre les deux ailes et termine à
quel point le consommateur est prêt à
recommander une marque ça peut être
basée sur une relation de confiance par
exemple mais au travers des canaux de
communication que sont les médias quel
type de relation entretenez-vous avec
ses tueurs nous citoyens lambda il va
pour revenir à la portance du
storytelling et médias ou en quelque
sorte remplacé les livres de notre
enfance les tueurs en série sont des
monstres moderne
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu hollywood
s'empare des serial killers des méchants
basé sur des histoires à la fois vrai et
hors du commun une figure du mal à la
personnalité complexe qui justifie que
le héros le combattent ces manichéen et
c'est clair c'est d'ailleurs comme dans
la réalité les profilers n'existe que
parce que les serial killers existe et
lorsque le tueur est carrément le
personnage principal de l'histoire on
parle d'anti héros plutôt que de
méchants ça mène à ce qu'on appelle le
syndrome hannibal lecter
on s'identifie davantage aux turcs à ses
victimes et comme nous l'avons dit nous
ne savons pas précisément pourquoi elle
céréales killer agi comme ça c'est donc
cette tache aveugle dans sa psyché que
l'on va tenter de remplir avec nos
explications et nos fantasmes
on a besoin de lui donner des raisons on
veut savoir pourquoi psychologie on
appelle ça la projection chercher à
comprendre empêche ainsi pas de
condamner les actes commis la très tient
ainsi plus d'une volonté d'éprouver de
l'empathie
voilà donc le type de relation que l'on
entretient avec les tueurs mais pourquoi
qu'est ce que tout ça nous fait
ressentir quelle image ça nous renvoie
de nous mêmes
les émotions véhiculées par une marque
facilite la mémoire en effet les gens se
souviennent davantage de ce qu'on leur
fait ressentir que ce qu'on leur dit une
marque aura toujours en effet sur une
personne au travers de ce qu'elle lui
propose comme par exemple l'association
d'appartenir à une communauté en
achetant tel produit est scellé ressenti
clôture provoquerait chez nous qui
expliquerait notre fascination
tout d'abord selon le psychiatre
christophe andré la peur est un système
d'alarmé nécessaire à notre survie et
les nécessaires qu'il reste bien réglée
c'est sans doute pour ça que l'on aime
se faire peur mais bien sûr uniquement
dans des conditions sécurisées devant
une fiction en mettant en scène un tueur
en série
mais ce n'est pas tout parce que les
tueur en série qui sont par nature des
personnes qui font le mal nous
reconditionne sur le manichéisme de la
société avec une vision dichotomique du
bien et du mal le chercheur américain
david schmitt explique dans son livre
natural born celebrities killers une
américaine culture que la fascination
pour les criminels qui sont des
personnes anormal et ne répondant pas
aux codes de la société permet de se
rassurer sur sa propre normalité de se
confirmer
je ne suis pas comme eux donc je suis
quelqu'un de bien si le meurtrier
fascine c'est donc avant tout parce que
comprendre son anormalité permettrait de
se rassurer sur sa propre normalité être
fasciné par le tueur en série est donc
tout ce qu'il ya de plus un ne pas s'y
intéresser du tout serait presque en
fait plus inquiétant
[Musique]
dans le cas d'une marque le reflet et
l'image que le consommateur renvoie aux
autres en s'appropriant cette remarque
par exemple une marque de chaussures
sportives donnera son entourage la
pression qu'on un sportif cela contribue
notamment au statut social mais que nous
sommes comme image le fait d'aimer les
céréales killer celle de quelqu'un de
cool et dj ou celle d'un détraqué
admirateur de meurtre aucun des deux vu
qu'il s'agit en fait de quelque chose de
tout à fait humain s'intéresser au tueur
en série est normal parce que nous
sommes capables de séparer la fiction et
la réalité le problème c'est quand on ne
fait pas la distinction et qu'on entre
dans l'excès il existe par exemple des
collections privées dans lesquelles on
peut trouver des objets et des oeuvres
ayant appartenu ou dont les auteurs sont
des tueurs en série il s'agit d'un
enregistrement de chansons de charles
manson ou encore des peintures faites
par john wayne gacy le kun tueur on peut
également y trouver des dessins de kral
par richard ramirez condamné à mort pour
avoir tué et violé plus d'une dizaine de
femmes
certains sites proposent des ventes aux
enchères il est par exemple possible
d'acheter pour 800 $ à burrito que
charles manson n'avait pas terminé dans
sa cellule
ce business du morbide quelque peu
déplacé s'appelle moeurs de ram il ya
les pèlerinages sont également
organisées sur des lieux où certains
crimes ont été commis
est ce trop plein de fascination peut
monter jusqu'à rentrer dans le domaine
de la pathologie
là où la passion devient attirance cela
s'appelle libristes au filet ou syndrome
de bonnie and clyde soit le fait d'être
attirée sexuellement par un individu
ayant commis un crime
la pathologie n'est pas rare et les
tueurs les plus célèbres entretiennent
régulièrement des relations épistolaires
romantique depuis leur prison alors
jusqu'à se marier avec leurs fans comme
c'est le cas pour charles manson qui
était marié à une femme de 26 ans depuis
sa prison peu avant sa mort à 83 en 2017
la journaliste isabelle horlans a même
interviewé dans son livre l'amour fou
pour un criminel des killers groupies
des véritables communautés de fans
hardcore de céréales killers sur les
réseaux sociaux et les témoignages font
froid dans le dos si cette fascination
est ce qui fait de nous des humains et
que s'y intéressaient ne veut pas dire
l'encourager il est tout de même
important de rappeler qu' elle limite
entre fascination sel et admiration
malsaine envers les tueurs en série en
bref le serial killer a beau avoir tous
les traits de la marque à succès le
mieux c'est tout simplement se contenter
de regarder des films
merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo si
vous l'avez apprécié n'hésitez pas à
mettre en pouces en l'air à vous abonner
à activer la cloche a commenté partager
si vous voulez en parler
pouvez nous rejoindre sur le discorde du
vortex
[Musique]
quel juste morte de rire finalement
cellule mais oui puis surtout personne
n'y croira jamais entassons on va aller
à la police
non mais non on les accusait mode déjà
j'ai les épisodes et écrire peut alors
aux tensions ce week-end ça va ça
m'arrange pas vraiment d'être suspecté
dans une affaire où il ya un mort mais
en plus c'est un peu louche d'avoir un
canal sur le canapé depuis deux jours le
chien commence à tourner autour vous
déconnez là on va pas la police moi je
propose la démocratie et le statu quo en
cas d'égalité c'est d'accord avec ça
élever la marche vous êtes d'accord il
sort et qui votent pour qu'on ne dise
pas vous déconnez elle a en fait on va
pas les la police vous savez que c'est
une obligation légale en fait d'aller à
la police cantonale un cadavre sur les
bras
vous voulez qu'on soit complice vous
voulez que notre taille elle soit foutu
à cause d'une erreur
[Musique]
bon
ah oui si vous voulez qu'on parle
davantage de céréales killer tout ça je
suis à la sortie de cette vidéo en ce
moment même en live sur machine twitch
alors le lien ça fait juste là où alors
il dans la description
bref venez maintenant ça va être
mortelle